Her low freak bitches will probably have
a following of Irish people to,
you know what I mean?
Who Cares?
Who gives a fuck?
Speaking of the Irish speaking,
I've got them right here.
Oh Man.
Hey listen,
man,
this guy has balls.
This is why I respect the fuck out of
conor Mcgregor.
Not just because he's an awesome fighter
and yeah,
he lost the Nate Diaz who's also an
awesome fighter,
but who the fuck will fight anybody who
will just jump up?
The light goes,
Bj.
Bj tried it and you know what?
Even though a Bj didn't,
he had success once,
at least at one 70 he beat mad.
He's,
but at the end of the day,
there's a really good reason why all
elite boxers,
wrestlers,
fighters,
weight cutting is so massively
important.
Virtually everybody,
there are some crazy people out there
like Anthony Johnson.
That's the exception,
but generally there's a really good
reason most people are torturing
themselves to get as light as possible
because at the elite level,
five pounds makes a big fucking
difference.
It makes a big difference.
Just five pounds,
10 pounds,
10 pound different elite level men.
Even the best guys aren't going up
looking at half a Mendez.
No doubt.
Probably pound for pound.
The best guy in Jujitsu,
probably him and Marcello,
John,
Jack,
they're all up there.
Pam,
pound for pound.
There's so many good guys now.
Jesus.
It's incredible now.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
you know,
even Marcello Nolan's trying to go up in
weight.
No one's trying to go,
let me do this year.
I'm going to try the weight category
above me.
Know everybody's on the craziest died.
They need three months.
They get serious about it.
They're on instagram posts in their
fucking broccoli every day with chicken.
Fucking selfies of their,
of their hubs and shit.
You know it,
they're killing themselves because not
because it feels good.
It feels like shit.
They all love eating it.
It's so important.
Uh,
so everybody knows you just can't go up
and goddamn white.
Bj was,
Bj was the one that said,
fuck it.
He went up to light heavyweight and
shit.
Chino,
five foot eight.
No,
it wasn't even light heavyweight,
Bro.
It was heavyweight.
Because Leo Machida was like two Oh
eight.
Okay.
I think that fight was like technically
a heavyweight fight.
Find that out.
But with
Cheetah,
you know what I mean?
He was fat for shorter.
That's out of shame.
And did you ever see when he used to
fight kickboxing fat,
his first UFC fight,
that's not his real weight has real
weight is two oh five one and 485.
So,
uh,
but Bj did it and I always admired him.
I,
I to me animal to me,
I looked,
I'll always look at,
Bj has a living legend.
Yeah,
the guy didn't,
he's not undefeated.
He got his ass beat a few times.
Who gives a fuck look would be jay did,
he had the balls to step up and really
he was a 45 or just like just a car the
whole time he was a foreigner and
Jujitsu.
He was a 45 or,
yeah,
he was always a 45 or fighting at 55
bod.
I won 70.
Nobody else is doing it.
And you know,
Connor,
here he comes.
this guy,
uh,
um,
he has so much power in his hands.
He had that courage to think he could
finish what Bj started,
you know,
let me go up there and do that.
Do what Bj did.
But you know,
he felt like he could fucking knock
anybody out.
He really,
really believed he could fucking,
he will be lands.
You're going down and you know what?
He was doing great against Nate Diaz.
I ma,
this is my,
this is how I found out.
Okay.
I'm Juan.
I'm at,
I'm at this party,
slam his house and uh,
I didn't realize we were behind by a
minute and a half that we rely,
oh,
I thought we were alive,
but we were behind by a man and
everyone's going nuts.
I'm watching going,
oh shit.
Lizzie borden is sitting next to me.
My childhood idol.
He's one of my greatest,
favorite lead singers of all time.
We sit next to him or watching
everyone's going nuts.
It looks like Connor's to me.
I was like,
Connor's gonna win this thing,
man.
He was lightened,
made up,
cutting them all up.
He was connecting.
He looked really confident like car look
call that whole first round I was gone.
It's,
it's uh,
it,
it was over in the forced second stock
and there was a second.
So in that round I get a call from Joey,
Joey's,
I go,
oh,
you know how much I want.
You know how much I told you?
I told you,
you never bet against Diaz.
I go,
what are you talking about?
I thought it was watching it.
Are you talking about the Meesha fight?
He goes,
no,
motherfucker,
you got choke.
Like who got choked up a call?
The home got choked out.
I'm watching the date and he has no
motherfucker.
What thought are you watching right now?
I'm watching the quarter pipe as it's
going on.
He goes,
he choked him fucking out.
I'm like,
dude,
fuck.
And he goes by boom.
He realized he fucked up.
And I'm like,
and I knew that Diaz was going to win a
minute.
You've wasn't to pee or something.
We were at a party and it was just
behind someone rewound wound shit.
Rewind.
Should you want to see something again?
And you didn't fast forward it.
So we thought it was live.
So Joey,
Joey called me hysterical and he gave it
away.
And then once he realized he gave it
away,
he hung up because Oh shit.
And I said,
Oh shit by you just fucked up the
greatest fight ever.
But the fight was so crazy and so
fucking insane that even though I knew,
even though I knew,
I go,
okay,
somehow nate is going to take him down
and choke him out,
but it doesn't look good right here.
I'm like,
how is he going to take an connor down?
That's not going to be easy.
Fuck,
he's going to pull this off.
How is he going to do it?
Had no idea that nate,
nate hurts connor.
Connor takes him down.
You know?
That's how it went down.
The place I was at was going fucking
nuts.
Everybody was screaming at the top of
the fucking logs.
Every everyone's,
and then when he choked him out,
dude,
I never been in a party where everyone
was going so crazy before everybody was
losing their fucking mind.
I was too holy shit blinds.
Everybody was going crazy.
Oh Man.
Jumped up and screamed.
I almost had an,
I never screamed so loud in my
motherfucking life at any fight ever.
That was shocking.
It was the same.
It looked like Carla was just had his
hands down cause I got this
motherfucker,
he was landon,
he was tagging him.
It looked like you heard him a couple of
times.
He definitely tag them.
You know what I mean?
It looked,
he was,
I thought it was uh,
it was over for nate.
I really did.
And when he turned it around and the way
it finished and when he put that fucking
rear naked choke and he put that
motherfucker and like a Super Ninja,
the weight,
first of all,
the way he mounted,
if you don't do Jujitsu,
you would never know the way he fucking
mounted and his balance.
You could see the balance.
You could see the beauty in that mound
and the way he was riding him,
like a professional fucking a champion
Rodeo.
Fucking reiner,
all is balanced is all beautiful.
And then when he took his back,
the way he put that fucking Hook in
there was,
it was so efficient.
There wasn't no hiccup where he hit the,
you know,
uh,
this jaw and then he had to set up and
then you got to feel,
it just went,
it was fucking insanity.
So perfect.
And so fucking like that technique was
about is flawless and as beautiful as
you can get.
Yeah,
there was two big points was that we had
never seen conor face adversity and we
had never seen him on the ground with a
real Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
Like nate.
Nate's got a nasty ground game man.
His ground now.
You know what,
people are talking in a lot of shit on
Congress.
Jujitsu.
I know Connor's digits is good.
He's come to my school.
That guys good just cause he got
mountain.
Yeah,
he was already here.
But even if he wasn't her,
I get mounted by my purple belt
sometimes and I get my bag.
There's some shit going on and add
punches and fucking all this height.
Just cause he got mountain and got his
back taking does not mean connor's
Jujitsu sucks.
Don't get it twisted.
He was a little hurt.
Nate Diaz is really good.
Really,
really good.
You know what I mean?
Like Nate Diaz could probably do that to
me.
Doesn't mean I suck.
You know what I mean?
He could probably get my back.
Doesn't mean I suck.
I'm a high,
you know,
so.
Well he got hurt and it's real simple.
When you get tagged,
the way he got tagged and what you're
trying to take.
Nate Diaz down,
he got hurt.
He probably had no idea what the fuck he
was doing.
You know,
I haven't had an MMA fight,
but sean was telling me about when
Travis Brown hit him and that he was
like,
dude,
I know how to get out of the mountain.
But when travis hit me,
he's like,
I didn't know what I was doing.
He was,
I was out of it.
I think that we mustn't get punched in
the face.
You can't judge his Jujitsu.
It's like judging is walking.
If you get head kicked connor,
she jitsu good.
Nate Diaz.
Jujitsu is just way better.
You know what I'm saying?
If that's all it is,
sunny punches you in the face and then
you walk funny like,
man,
you need to work on your walking.
No,
they got memes of connor like it like
him in like a kids Jiu Jitsu class and
they put it in place.
That's one that's going around.
I think that's hurt.
You know what he's heard?
He is good.
Trust me,
connors.
Jujitsu is very,
very standard to Ross.
To me,
he's not a joke,
especially in that first round was nasty
standup look very good.
And he's just a look.
First of all is Nate Diaz is not a real
one.
70 all they did fight one 70 twice.
He fought us.
Dungan Kim and the fobt,
uh,
rory.
Rory Macdonald,
remember that?
Fought those guys at one 70 so he did
have two fights at one 70 but he's a one
55 or he's a big one.
55 or he's big and long.
I don't know if he could ever make one
45 I just don't think he could do it.
Connor barely can do it.
You know,
connor barely can do it.
When you see conor at the weigh ins,
I mean those photos from the winds are
pretty legendary.
I think it's insane that we do this,
that we let these guys dehydrate
themselves like that.
I think whatever nate walks around that
that's what he should fight at.
And I don't know if connor really walks
around at one 68 which what he weighed
in and nate raid one 69 they're only one
pound different.
And Nate,
you know nate had some body fat on him
cause he wasn't,
it wasn't preparing for this at all.
I think connor,
I think connor could make some noise at
one 55 shrink down.
I'm sure you see the two of those
together.
Can we do it?
Look at,
look at the difference between how he
weighed in before and how we wait in
this time.
I mean,
my God,
he looks like he has some fucking crazy
disease that like won't let food absorb
in his body on the top one,
you know like he's got some crazy
illness and then on the bottom he looks
great full faced.
But you know if he can make one 45 he's
going to continue to do it.
Can you think gets in the ring card?
Girls are like sitting right there.
Is that an accident is perfect for the
pictures.
That's why they stand their ultimate
man.
It's to balance out that dude in the
underwear.
That's exactly,
that's funny.
That's funny.
That's an accurate,
he could completely dominate.
Continue to dominate the one 45 division
and I think he could make a lot of epic
fights at one 55 five went beat some big
names but then lose to some other big
names.
Like he'll be one of the top guys at 55
I don't know if he'll just clean house
like he did it 45 but I believe if he
stayed at 55 he would do some serious
damage.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Shit.
He's saying after the fight,
that perfect ship.
Perfect Shit.
I love what he's doing.
What?
I love how he's handling it.
I think he handled it.
His laws better than anybody ever,
ever.
He said on the right,
she'll in victory.
And I'm be humbling defeat.
No matter what happened in that fight,
his next fight,
whoever he's fighting,
he's going to get fucked up.
You know what I mean?
Mean.
What if you faced Los Angeles,
you know,
tough fight.
He's going to cut them up.
I bet he tags him a few times.
I bet you're right.
I bet he tags and I bet you're right.
You can tag everybody to hit some people
and just cause he got knocked out.
A lot of people,
half the people get knocked out and
fights.
He got knocked out,
he got,
he got cracked and you've got choked.
But um,
I'm interested in to see how he handles
the physicality of Dos Anjos who's a lot
more physical than nate.
You know,
dos Santos is a beast.
I wanna.
I wanna know if he could do to connor,
what he was able to do to nate,
but he was able to do to a lot of guys
like pettis.
What he did,
the Pedis,
you know that guy strong as shit,
but that was so bummed out when he broke
his foot.
I was like,
God,
that's a crazy fight and so it's going
to be there,
but fucking nate,
all of a sudden they
that little stoner is going to be,
he's probably sweet dude.
He's,
he's super famous now.
Everybody knows your name.
Come on dude.
Greatest all time.
Post fight line.
I got it today.
I'm not surprised motherfuckers.
No,
it's funny.
You know what dude?
In the beginning,
conor won the verbal that battles the
first couple press commerce.
He kinda did.
Connor came full blown and then nate,
nate one towards the end.
Dude,
I felt that nate was in connor's head.
I think it reversed at bay.
I think he was pissing connor off that
he kept saying,
fuck you.
He just went gangster on them.
Every time my crew will fuck up your
crew.
Like I said,
if you want to make this fucking serious
week,
we're going to pass by you guys
somewhere in this motherfucking hotel.
We'll jump.
You will do that.
You guys want to do it will actually
jump you guys and it'll be all over
fucking shirt done the shit.
You're Dana White.
What do you do
with Misha Dude?
Blower up.
She's huge.
Who Rages?
I don't know man,
but give her a world tour first.
She won one of the greatest victories in
the history of MMA.
Damn down down on the scorecards in the
fourth round with two minutes to go.
She hits a takedown,
takes her back,
almost get shook over the top,
hangs on,
hangs on.
That was so dramatic.
That was like the end of the thought.
So smart.
She fought so smart.
She did everything that all the experts
were saying she was going to need to do.
She did everything she avoided and kicks
in Russian and she had to pull it off
like the,
what was that?
Our minute left.
Tell me how much dislike,
like somewhere around two minutes to go
when she went for the take down.
When she,
when she got ahold of her.
So you're down to last round.
Last round edge wasn't winning the
round.
Nothing really had happened.
That was like big and significant.
She had a take down 10,
probably lose it on the cards.
Crappy.
I didn't look at the cards,
but you know,
she won that one round for sure when she
took her down and that went,
made everybody go,
oh shit.
Is that the second?
Was it the second round that she took
her down?
This was dominating her?
Um,
yeah,
I think it was the second.
Her meesha is wrestling me.
Her wrestling is a lot better than
before.
Before she's hustling dude.
She hustled.
She keeps getting better.
Holly Holm and easy to take down.
Take down the fence.
That's like her main shit.
Um,
she probably works on her takedown
defense more than her Jujitsu.
So this is the cards.
Yeah.
So what does it say and basically what
are we doing here?
You should take this hard to do,
these are confusing.
White,
blue,
pink.
There's a pink card,
I guess the Oh,
the different people just as the
referee's names.
Um,
okay.
So round nine so ten nine well,
who's red and who's blew me?
She has blue blue on the left.
Oh,
okay.
So how,
yeah,
so it must've been the,
hmm.
That's interesting.
Wait,
wait a minute.
All three at ten nine for the first
right.
All three had ten eight for the second.
Right.
That makes sense.
And all three at ten nine for the third
and for the fourth.
So does that make it a draw?
No,
that means holly was ahead.
Well,
how do they judge the fourth and then
the fifth she was ahead in the fourth so
holly was ahead by one point,
right?
Yep.
Even though she'd won three rounds.
Yes.
I mean ten eight if she would have won
that round,
it would have been a draw,
I guess.
Wow.
But she was,
she wasn't really winning on the round.
I'm surprised that they all gave him a
ten eight that's good.
That's very good.
Good.
Good job,
Bill.
Today their name's Marcos for solids.
Good job.
Yeah,
that was,
yeah,
that was a real ten eight that's how 10
h should look.
Someone takes it down,
beat the shit out of you.
But just what an what a finish.
That was.
What was amazing about it and you know
holly fought smart,
she used that side kick a lot.
She's so good with their movement.
She caught me should with a lot of
punches to man,
but she wasn't,
she wasn't going after her.
She would catch it with punches and stay
on the outside.
She was fighting a smart fight and she
got taken down.
She got dominated on the ground by
Meesha and that's when I was like wow.
Neesha's fucking top game is solid as a
rock.
Like our control is excellent and she's
fucking strong man.
She's strong cause holly's strong.
Holly Holm is strong.
I was really impressed with their ground
and pound really impressed with your top
game.
But then you know what man,
the next round Holly Holm got right back
on her fucking bicycle and,
and and probably in everyone's eyes and
when that round right,
all those judges eyes I was,
to me it was a,
if that would have wanted a decision
that would have given it to holly.
Yeah.
Just based on,
uh,
you know,
depending upon how that feel,
real damage.
She never knocked me shut down.
She never hurt me.
She right.
It was the shipper I heard,
never heard her.
She tagged her a couple times where,
you know,
she snapped her head back a little bit,
but it wasn't anything like was she
alone was wrong.
Yeah.
Legs giving out.
No.
So it,
it,
it was,
it was about to be a semi boring
decision overall.
Like who would want to watch that fight
again?
The second round was kind of cool.
It was going to be one of those fights,
but just like that me shit turned it
into one of the greatest fights ever.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And I come back that last second.
That's like a grand slam and the bottom
of the ninth in the scramble to get to
the back.
Her scramble,
the way she held on as Holly Hollywood
kept moving and changing and adjusting.
She kept holding on.
Then finally the Hail Mary Hollie tries
to flip her over the top and she hangs
on and hangs on to the choke and sinks
it in and gets the hooks in and,
and when holly goes to sleep,
punching in the air,
you know those,
you know those old nfl films,
like when you watch those at the super
bowl from 1978 or something and have
that voice in the toddler,
they're doing the slow mo and these all
these old,
you know,
memorable plays at epic plays in 20
years.
When they look back at that and they
have some old like Orson Welles type a
narrator talking about,
you know,
about going through all that transition
and there was a lot of drama going on
there,
man.
She didn't just take her back and choke
her.
There was a lot of shit.
There was a lot of shit to handle.
So much was going on.
And you gotta watch this happening.
Yeah,
it was incredible to rear naked choke.
The scramble scramble was just so epic
because the drama building up,
he,
she's down on the cards most likely you
can't watch that.
Were watched.
No,
we can never watch does.
She's down in the cards.
Most likely she's about to,
she's about to lose a decision probably.
Oh my God.
She's got a hold of her.
She's on her back.
Oh my God.
You got that joke.
It just kept going and going back.
And then when holly went to sleep,
I was like,
she didn't even tap.
She's went out.
She went out punching.
She was throwing punches when she went
out to y'all.
Bad Ass.
You have to be to go out throwing
punches and how bad ass that girl is.
She went out,
she went out like throwing punches.
She didn't want to tap.
Fuck.
That was a good fight.
Woo.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Back was the best fight of the night.
That was that the biggest UFC ever.
I mean,
Jesus,
that was the biggest UFC ever.
I mean,
I would say I the fight of the night,
but he's not the fight of the night.
It's the same.
They're both equally insane.
There's no like one better finale or one
better.
Uh,
and I think the conor fight was more
excited because all the way through
there was a lot of damage going on and
it was a lot of fire gone on with the
holly fight.
There was a lot of dancing around taking
shots.
It was a Lotta,
you know,
definitely what it was.
There was a lot less action overall.
Yeah.
But if you compress those,
if you take out a couple of those rounds
and compress it all into one round,
then yeah,
I see.
I don't think you gotta be pleased by it
through the whole thing.
I think what's most important is that
it,
after it ends,
you have some like definitive conclusion
that if it takes a while to get that
definitive conclusion,
I mean it's going to give a two
firefighters are tactical.
You're right.
But it was because of that that made the
end so good.
Without that then it wouldn't have been
so juicy at the end.
Exactly.
Because she had gone through the full
five or when they were in the fifth
round and it was like,
we've got to see,
she's trying things and not working.
She tries this.
It works really good.
Okay.
Now Holly's trying this,
that's working meets his,
trying that.
That's not working.
Okay.
Now she don't start a kick,
which should go,
Ooh,
she got to do something different to get
close to her.
How's she going to figure it out?
Down on the score.
Shoots for the fucking take down.
Grabs a hold of her,
gets her neck jokes or unconscious.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
cause yeah,
you wouldn't have been that low from
that stuff to the place went insane.
It was insane.
It was so epic.
And then download Misha tate.
Man.
God Damn,
she was so happy.
She's so nice.
You know?
She's such an like her and holly,
they're both so nice.
It's so nice to see like nice people
like that do really well in such a
brutal savage sport.
You know?
She's really nice.
Like when have you ever used
[inaudible]?
Never like raised her voice at anybody.
She never yelled at anybody.
She's like real friendly.
She's real sweet to see her.
The UFC bantamweight champion.
I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Well,
I wonder performance.
I think holly is a little bit nicer
though.
She's so nice too.
It seems like they're just so some
country like wife.
You know what I mean?
She's the preacher's daughter.
She was,
yeah,
she is.
She really is.
Wow,
and she's tough as fuck,
dude.
She went out punching out cold.
She was like throwing punches.
She just wants to get the in post high.
Then she just wanted to get back into
it.
She was like,
when do you,
she just wants to get back in.
Getting back.
What I loved about the preflight speech
when she was talking about the fight
itself,
she was like,
you know what?
Rhonda is going to be out for awhile.
She was,
I'm not fighting for money.
I'm not fighting for fame.
I want the action.
I want to fight.
I'm like,
Whoa,
how wild.
What does he,
that's how you got to think.
If you want to be great,
right.
It's any one of them to focus on.
Yeah.
If you want to be a holly Holm,
I guess you have to be like that.
You want to be a 19 time worlds women
boxing champion,
you've got to be like a crazy motivated
person.
She's got to,
she's got to fall in love with Jujitsu
though,
cause she's not the biggest fan of.
She did say she really needs that and
that to us before.
I know that.
I know that that's hard to swallow,
you know,
but uh,
you got to,
you can't be one of those fighters that,
and there's a bunch of them out there,
uh,
that,
they didn't really want to get
offensively good at Jujitsu.
They didn't really,
uh,
have,
they weren't attracted to passing the
guard,
taking the back and choking PPI.
There's a lot of wrestlers out there
that just want her to keep it on the
feet,
do a little take down the fence.
And if you have to take them down,
stay in half guard and pound them out
and just keep it simple and keep it like
that.
You know,
if,
um,
there's a lot of wrestlers like that.
Not that she's the restaurant,
they're strikers.
They're strikers like that too.
There's been a quite a few throughout
the years,
champions that didn't really want to
work on their,
did you get to the right way,
the right way,
which is sparring with everybody and not
picking her up,
sparring opponents and just jumping in
into the fire.
That's how I know o'connor's good
because connor does that and he's going
to get way better.
He's actually good at Jujitsu is there's
a lot better.
But I think holly needs to have somehow,
somehow it needs to happen.
I don't know how,
but uh,
she needs to fall in love with Jujitsu
and,
and uh,
because I think that's where people
know,
I mean that's the spot we already,
we haven't really seen her on her back.
We w we haven't seen her react to
Jujitsu and now we have,
and Mischa just exposed her and she
needs to get take that she needs to take
care of that and fall in love with Jiu
Jitsu and started getting on Instagram,
taking pictures with their gay,
you know what I mean?
And she's got a blue belt and be all
happy.
She's got to be really happy about it
because um,
she needs,
uh,
there's,
there's a hole right there and that's
what people are going to try to take
her.
Yeah,
just not that hard to take down.
After all I thought she'd be harder to
take down but you know me,
she took her down for me.
She mixes up or take down times.
She goes at the time
and she goes down low.
Where's Rhonda is like upper body
clench.
She's really an upper body clench so all
holly had to do also Rhonda in that
fight was so insanely aggressive.
Her charging after made it so much
easier for counters me.
She was super crafty.
Yep.
She liked very patient,
very patient,
varied.
Her movement varied or timing didn't do
any like,
like she didn't continue any patterns
with this.
Her stand up,
she moved around a lot and she did a lot
of Juke in and a lot of,
she did a lot of different stuff.
Stayed on the outside,
made holly come after her.
Like if you,
if you're,
if you're a really good counter striker
like holly is for her,
the best thing is a Rhonda,
like someone's gonna run at her.
The best thing is someone running
addict.
She's,
she's so fleet like her footwork.
So excellent.
She sold light on her feet that she's so
good at just sliding out of the way and
cracking you while you coming in.
It's like one of the things she's best
at.
So if you fight that way against her,
that's the kind of fight that happens.
You look,
she looks like a master,
but if you look at her fight in the very
first UFC fight,
we were Raquel Pennington.
She wants to split decision.
Yeah.
You know,
and that was a fight where were cal
fought more cautious,
a little smarter,
new,
new holly's background coming in.
You know,
if you don't like,
if you don't engage with her,
it's like,
remember when Anderson was in his prime,
if guys came after him,
he just butchered him.
But if guys hung back,
sometimes a fight was boring,
right?
Like,
um,
Talis,
late tests.
Remember tonsillitis,
like hung back and he kind of waited for
Anderson.
Um,
same thing with Patrick [inaudible].
Patrick [inaudible] hung back.
He just fought smart.
He's like,
I'm going to charge it and running into
anything.
Come,
come get me,
come get me.
And [inaudible] like,
oh,
he's had a big right hand.
So everybody had to be real careful.
You always had to be careful because a
guy,
if you're coming at him,
he could always catch you.
And if a guy like coattail catches you,
he just had that stupid power in his
hand.
He could just knocked.
He knocked out Tito at two oh five.
You remember that?
He knocked him out down,
knocked him down.
Tito don't take a shot,
but he knocked him down at two oh five
and he fights at one 70 now.
You know,
I mean,
Patrick Code taken crack.
So Anderson never want,
remember I,
Patrick blew his knee out in that fight.
Yeah.
He like went to throw a kick and his
knee just gave out.
It's right.
Exploded.
Yeah.
He fought a very smart fight too.
And that's that stain when you,
you find a killer counterstrike or like
that.
The big thing is like let them lead.
They don't,
they don't want to lead.
Make it a boring fight.
Let it be boring.
Move around,
be patient.
Me,
she did everything right man.
It's amazing.
Rhonda.
Me Three would be nice,
right?
That's probably what it's going to
happen.
It's probably what's gonna happen next
according to,
uh,
what I've led on the internets cause I
was have here I wanted to,
what Rhonda would want,
would she want a
rematch with her after a loss or I would
title shot if I was her out was a tough
choice.
Rather,
if I was her,
I was her,
I'd pure boy.
Tough choice,
right?
Boy,
I can't be her.
I,
if I was her,
honestly I would probably,
I would imagine if I was her,
I'd want to avenge the loss cause holly
was her first loss and she doesn't feel
like she did her best in that fight and
that fight was just,
she had too much going on.
If you hear her talk about it,
it was like there was,
she's overwhelmed with obligations and
shit and just fought wrong.
Just didn't,
didn't fight correctly,
just had real problems going into that.
And then you have like her approach like
getting in Holly's face the way in and
try and make it real emotional,
you know,
you fake ass bitch and all that stuff.
And then all that emotions when she
fought in the ranks just running after
holly and holly just fall like a master,
that was one of the best performances
you'll ever see of a striker and
negating a person to aggression.
Like she just did it so brilliantly.
Catching her with elbows coming in,
catching it with straight lefts and then
that fucking set up for the head kick
when Rhonda is all stumbling and she
just catches her with that head kick.
I mean just to spectacular mixed martial
arts performance overall,
like one of the best like title winning
efforts in any weight class as far as
like a sheer domination,
it's right up there with Tj dillashaw
Hanan Barao one but more,
probably more scary.
It's one of the most spectacular
highlight clips ever.
She's getting clipped.
Yup.
Wow.
Amazing.
It's like she's a bad ass,
you know.
So what I think about holly is,
you know,
holly get back on track and uh,
I,
I really hope that she takes that advice
that you just gave.
I think that'd be real smart.
He's got to somehow fall in love with
and not fight it no more.
Well,
I dunno if she fights it.
I don't know what the deal is.
Who knows?
You know,
she's just so good at kickboxing.
I think,
uh,
she just wants to stay,
sharpen that.
And that's what she wants to do to girls
because she feels like she has this big
advantage of them against them in that.
But obviously she needs a little work on
it and I think she'll get better,
man.
She,
she can,
she could still improve,
you know,
and I think maybe there's also the
overwhelming pressure that must come
from being a champ.
Like that experience probably takes a
while and they'll learn how to navigate
it.
I hope I'm wrong and she's already in
love with it.
That would be awesome if that was wrong.
And I'm rooting for Holly.
I like holly.
I think holly,
could you not hallway with?
Of course.
How could I not like it?
I'm just being real.
I'm sorry if it hurts anybody's
feelings.
No,
I,
what you're saying is important.
I hope,
and I hope that I'm wrong.
I hope that you have no idea.
She's
totally into,
she's been all,
she just hasn't worked on it that long
or whatever,
but,
uh,
that's,
I would love to see holly home with,
uh,
aggressive offer back and dangerous
offer back.
There's no reason why she couldn't be.
She's super athletic.
She has a crazy work ethic.
Okay.